the google cloud cli
what is it the google cloud command line
interface also known as the google cloud
cli is a set of command line tools that
are used to access the many services on
google cloud
as part of the google cloud sdk the cli
makes it easy for developers and
administrators to manage their cloud
resources and infrastructure from their
linux mac
or windows terminal
you can also access it without having to
download or install anything by using
cloud shell our in-browser shell
environment
several command line tools are bundled
within the google cloud cli
first there's gcloud the primary cli
tool used to customize your local
configuration manage authentication and
let you access a majority of google
cloud resources
there are a lot of things you can do
with gcloud spin up a virtual machine on
compute engine create a database on
cloud sql grant iam roles and
permissions to users and service
accounts manage your organization's
policies
and much more
virtually anything you can do in the
google cloud console by pointing and
clicking you can also do with a
corresponding gcloud command several
other clis and tools come bundled within
the google cloud cli including bq for
interacting with bigquery from the
command line
with bq you can create and manage
bigquery resources like datasets jobs
and transfers and run queries on your
bigquery tables
next there's gsutil for accessing cloud
storage from the command line if you're
accessing cloud storage buckets you'll
use gsutil to create list and delete
buckets as well as upload download and
manage the objects stored in them
and what's more gcloud can run a number
of emulators that will generate data for
bigtable
datastore firestore pub sub and spanner
for use in your local development
environment
all of these command line tools gcloud
bq gsutil and others can be used
interactively or programmatically in any
automated scripts
so how do you get started using the
google cloud cli
if you already have a google cloud
project you'll find it pre-installed in
cloud shell
for local development it's supported for
linux macos and windows operating
systems and requires python to run
you can install it through your
operating system's package manager and
once installed the google cloud cli
supports updates so you'll always have
access to the latest changes and
features available on google cloud
you can find complete installation
instructions at cloud.google.com
cli
for more on google cloud cli and how you
can get started using it check out the
links in the description of this video
thanks for watching
[Music]
you